[Music]
thank you
coming up we put your questions about
growing up to the doctor and author Zoe
Williams
[Music]
and the three of us are finding out how
girls are being encouraged to enter the
world of Motorsports I can definitely be
the next generation
[Music]
hi this is FYI the weekly newsure that
explains everything that's happening in
the world this week and we're going to
start with a route that's broken out
over cartoons on the walls of an
Immigration Center it's all about how
the UK welcomed children who have
arrived here on their own without their
families often after feeling from war
and danger in their own countries
they've often had terrible Journeys over
thousands of miles from countries like
Afghanistan or Syria or from war-torn
parts of Africa and they may have
crossed the channel in dangerous small
boats by the time they arrive here
they're often terrified and in shock
so send us like this one in Kent try to
make sure the children are well looked
after
they've been designed to be as charge
friendly as possible with cartoon
characters like Mickey Mouse on the
walls
but when the conservative government's
immigration Minister Robert Generac saw
the Disney characters he ordered them to
be painted over
the government has been trying to stop
small boats bringing people over the
channel illegally
so far of that much success and
apparently the minister thought the
cartoon characters were too welcoming
his decision has been heavily criticized
by Refugee groups and politicians from
all parties Lord ponsonby and I went to
the facility where that mural was there
was nothing offensive about it all it
did was provide comfort
and a sense of belonging to children in
a desperate situation the government is
sticking to its guns saying they look
after unaccompanied children properly
but wants to stop them from making these
perilous Journeys in the first place
well we're joined now from Turkey by 14
year old Banner who fights for Refugee
Rights after fleeing the Syrian War
Banner you escaped with your family but
it was still a really scary time wasn't
it yes indeed it was very scary because
the thought of losing your family member
on the way does not leave your mind and
the fact that we were children and tried
our best to act like adults just to
reach the buses was not easy and the
thing is that on the whole journey me
and my brothers were just hugging each
other thinking that if we held each
other we would stay safe and still be
together now your cousin Muhammad fled
Syria on his own when he was just 12 I
mean he's the same age as me why did he
do it and what was his experience like
so his parents gave him a big
responsibility to get out of Syria in a
legal way so first of all he went to
Turkey and then he went with a buyer
cargo ship in a small box can you
imagine his parents were really afraid
that he would like get suffocated or
anything but we children are just
thinking of we need the better future we
want to study we want to make our
parents proud of us because like the war
is so scary and we don't want anyone to
live like that what is your message for
the British government children are very
important they don't they do not deserve
to die or they do not deserve to be
kicked out and stay as a refugee in a
place they do not know without their
parents
also like we are children right our
parents take care of us and they don't
want us to be harmed
they all have children
so why do they bother to also like kick
out other children
it's
unbelievable thank you so much Banner
thank you for your time bye
[Music]
now strangely Mickey Mouse is also
popping up on social media in relation
to the second world war this image
claims to be a Mickey Mouse gas mask
made for children in case of a gas
attack but is it fake or fact
I'm going much further back this
painting was recently discovered on a
war in Pompeii the famous Italian city
buried by a volcanic eruption nearly 2
000 years ago some State shows an
ancient Pizza way before pieces were
supposed to have been invented so again
is this fake or fat we'll let you know
later
[Music]
now to an amazing true story which
definitely sounds fake it's that feeding
cows daffodils could help fight climate
change yet that really sounds like the
start of a joke I know but let me
explain cows produce about a seventh of
all greenhouse gas emissions and it
comes from gases in their stomachs so
cows Breaking Wind basically
you got it it's actually a big issue but
scientists at Scotland's rural College
discovered that a daffodil extract added
to cow's food massively reduces the
harmful gas they produce researchers say
it could be a real game changer and
they're starting a trial on farms all
over the country Wow real flower power
but just to note that daffodils are
poisonous to dogs so keep them away from
your pets
good point now I've got a tiny bit of
good news from the Amazon
the world's biggest rainforest has
suffered terrible destruction over
recent years but figures for the first
four months of 2023 show around a third
less was destroyed compared to last year
it's a positive start for the new
Brazilian president Lula who has
ambitious plans to stop illegal
rainforest destruction completely by
2030 but many say there's sadly little
chance of achieving that
is it just me or is it quite a tricky
time to be growing up yeah I agree I'm
not sure it's ever easy but it seems
there's a lot of bad stuff going on in
the world right now that kind of the
stuff we've been reporting on war
environment refugees yeah and then
there's personal pressures too of things
like social media so I'm delighted to
introduce Dr Zoe Williams to the FYI
Studio hi Zoe thank you so much for
joining us today thank you so much for
having me it's a pleasure to be here
well you recently brought out your girls
died to Growing Up called you grow girl
so why did you decide to write this when
I was growing up I wish there'd been a
resource that would sort of give me a
lot of answers to questions that I had
about the changes that were happening to
my body changes to relationships my
emotions being all over the place I've
tried to cover in the book all of those
challenges a very common concern amongst
girls is appearance and pressures to
look good yes so what advice would you
give to girls who might be a bit worried
about the way they look I think we put
far too much emphasis on the way way
that our bodies look to other people
because our bodies are so amazing if you
think of the things that they do not
just keeping us alive but all the things
that we can do with our bodies from
playing sport to dancing to our brains
like we are as human beings we are
incredible so whilst you know it'd be
unrealistic for me to sit here and say
we shouldn't be bothered at all about
how we look there are lots of tips and
tricks and activities that can help us
start to appreciate and love our real
selves and our amazing bodies for
everything that they do for us so
another question we got was making and
keeping friends yeah what advice would
you give to girls and boys who might be
concerned about that I think it's really
important to be able to identify the
difference between a good friendship and
a friendship that's maybe not so healthy
if you're in a good friendship you
should be able to trust them and be
honest with them and feel that you can
confide in them so yeah I think my
advice around making friends is it's
easier if you have a shared interest so
whatever your interests are get out
there join clubs be adventurous be
curious and always just look out for if
there are any red flags in friendships
and you should feel comfortable and safe
in a friendship sometimes we tend to end
up in friendships with people that are
like us or people that look like you and
you were talking about you know refugees
and I think refugees that move to this
country must start it must be really
difficult for them to make friendships
especially if they don't speak the
language so my advice is you know if
there is someone in your class at school
who you don't really feel that you
understand much about them ask some
questions and they might end up becoming
a really good friend well we've
mentioned bad news and there's been a
couple of upsetting stories over the
past week or so for instance there were
fatalities after a car crashed into a
prep school in Wimbledon and then there
was also a stabbing at a secondary
school in Tewkesbury but fortunately no
one was seriously hurt in that one so
what would your advice be to viewers who
might be feeling a bit worried or upset
about this
I think in this country and probably
around the world we have a habit to
amplify bad news more than good news so
it can feel like there's loads of bad
stuff happening in the world where
actually the majority of stuff happening
in the world is good so I think if
you're feeling a bit overwhelmed because
these bad news stories seem to keep
hearing them over and over again it's
important to remember that
those those situations are few and far
between and there's way more good stuff
for my last question what are your top
tips for growing up happy sometimes I
think girls more than boys but boys as
well we have a tendency to look at
ourselves in the mirror and be critical
don't do that let's give ourselves love
and affection how else can you grow up
happy we live in a world now where we
have lots of friends in real life we
have lots of friends probably online I
always say somebody on social media
makes you feel bad three times three
strikes and you're out you know don't
follow them anymore there's a lot going
on in the world that's outside of our
control but we do have control over how
much we subject ourselves to different
things well thank you so much for
joining us today and answering our
questions
thank you
now if you are assume would you hitch a
ride in the surfboard well that's
exactly what this Brave baby seal does
in San Diego in California nickname
Sammy he seems to really enjoy chilling
with the surfboards
[Music]
it feels like a great time to be a girl
in sport with the lionesses reigning
European Champions and about to go to
the Women's World Cup in Australia and
New Zealand well one sport that wants to
see more women competing alongside men
is Formula One Motor Racing Raiden and
Scarlett went to check out a new scheme
which encourages girls to get into motor
support
foreign
have you ever felt the need for speed
well you
well you know I've always loved the idea
but I've never had the chance to
actually give it a go only two women
have ever qualified to race in Formula
One and that was back in the 1970s so
now the sport wants to change all that
and give women more chances to progress
to the highest levels it all starts here
on a go-kart track and luckily we know
just the right person to tell us more
hiya guys yes
competing in court since I was seven
years old and what's great is that I see
loads of girls competing as well 45
000 girls visit venues like this one
every year but sadly only a tiny
percentage of them go on to become adult
racing drivers
to address that the new women's racing
series the Formula One Academy is
launching an initiative called discover
your drive
the aim of it is to get girls into
Motorsports from an early age identify
Who's Got Talent and support them from
there it's hoped that more girls can
then progress to become F1 Academy
drivers like Jessica Edgar who's only
18.
going wheel to wheel she started young
just like the girl she said to support
so what differences do initiatives like
these make it like puts it on a global
stage so that the young girls think
they're welcome to come and do this and
aim to be in our seats wonder when I
started I was always the only girl in my
class first and then carton I do think
maybe girls are a little bit forgotten
about and I think that we can just be as
good as the boys let's meet some of the
girls who are taking part could they be
the future Lewis Hamilton's so Lily
Rosie what are you most excited for
today
well I'm excited for this new track
because I've never been here before I
think isn't it I know it's nice massive
it is the biggest track I've ever been
on do you think you guys could be like
the next generation of F1 drivers
I can definitely be the next Generation
I can see that well I can't wait to see
you get in the carts and get racing are
you gonna beat me that's for sure well
this is gonna be fun then let's give it
a go
[Music]
foreign
let's see how we did I came third yeah
she beat me what's your time they got
53. they both beat me but I I beat
Braden though everybody look on the
leaderboard I beat Brayden fair and
sweat he beat both of us I mean yeah
soon I'm gonna be at your level though I
just need to come a couple more times so
would you be interested in doing it
again I definitely do it again on this
track definitely I find it really fun so
would you enjoy pursuing a future in
Formula One or a different type of
Motorsport it's something I'm really
good at and like I just I'm really
passionate about it next weekend is the
Formula One Hungarian Grand Prix and I'm
really excited because Brayden Zach and
I will be taking over some of the
coverage on Sky Sports
[Music]
so did you guess which of our earlier
stories were fake or facts while the
Mickey Mouse gas mask is fat around a
thousand were made during World War II
to help make putting them on less scary
for children
but the 2 000 year old Pompeii Pizza is
fake the picture is for real but if you
look closely it's just a kind of
flatbread with fruit on tomatoes a vital
ingredient of pizza didn't come to
Europe from the Americas till a few
centuries ago and pizzas were invented
in nearby Naples soon after in the 1700s
well that's just about it for this week
but Scarlet I saw that Taylor Swift
tickets just got on sale for her UK
concerts next year did you try to get
any well I didn't but loads of my
friends didn't it was really tricky I
mean the figures are just amazing Taylor
Swift is doing 151 concerts altogether
as part of her era's World Tour and it's
been estimated she makes about 10
million pounds for each show the demands
for tickets have been crazy I mean
websites in America are crashing badly
it seems you only have a 1 in 50 chance
of actually getting one or if you're
gonna try get a ticket I wish you the
best of luck till next week bye bye